Wow like it's legit we found out that
the windmill is Peter
my question is 10 out of 10 chemistry
did Peter get a heads up that you had to
reveal the two times in the windmill I
thought what I didn't have the heads up
in my brain yeah that that was gonna
come out but like did he know before the
episode aired I unclear okay
I cannot say honestly
[Music]
from obviously how you feel me gonna win
meal probably you probably want to leave
you ended up getting backed into a
corner and having to reveal your sex
life how frustrating was that for you it
was really frustrating for me I will be
very honest when asked anything but I
felt like that question was really
pointed because it was contingent on
whether he was going to stay or not or
really whether I was worthy of him his
love because before that he had said he
loved me he wanted to marry me but he
needed to know my intimacy with the
other guys for him to know if I was
worth it or not
is what it felt like it seemed and just
really was not okay for him to ask that
or to really for that to matter so much
like is that what you is your end-all
be-all for how you decide who you want
to spend the rest of your life with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]